jessica have i come in a bad time
gerald this is harvey specter
he's our best closer says here that
cooper won't be staying on as honorary
vice president
that's right i don't want him around he
wouldn't be around it's an honorary
position
i don't give a [ __ ] well i think you do
because
that's what's changed since i left which
means it's you who's been dealing in bad
faith
well now that you've got a grasp on
what's happened in the goddamn
interim what are you gonna do about it
because he's not getting that title
well let me make sure i understand this
okay we negotiated a deal that gave you
everything you wanted mr cooper signed
it
and now you won't close until we take
away the last shred of his dignity bingo
well that's not gonna happen and why the
hell not because i like mr cooper and my
firm doesn't operate in bad faith
oh i see how it is instead of working
cooper
you're working me why don't you take
your pansy attitude
back in there make him sign my deal or
i'll pay someone else your money to do
it for me
well first of all gerald if you think
anyone's gonna touch this deal after
your bad faith you're mistaken
second the way our agreement works is
the minute cooper signed the deal which
gave you everything you wanted
our fee was due and payable which is why
at 7 30
i received confirmation of a wire
transfer from escrow
indicating payment in full
so i'd say the ball's in your court but
the truth is your balls are in my fist
now i apologize if that image is too
pansy for you but i'm comfortable enough
with my manhood to put it out there
now get your ass in there and close the
goddamn deal
thought you weren't coming i had to
settle the case first
you have the paperwork we talked about
what is this a copy of the judicial
conduct codes
a friend of mine works at the attorney
general's office he gave it to me we had
a nice chat about you
i told him if you were willing to
blackmail someone once chances are
you've done it before
he's very anxious to meet you you think
you can get away with screwing my wife
and then have me investigated
you actually have it the wrong way
around the only thing i've done so far
is have you investigated what
i never actually slept with lauren but i
knew you'd never believe me so i kept my
mouth shut
but now that she's getting a divorce my
policy no longer applies
and of course she's free to date whoever
she pleases
and she pleases me
enjoy your evening donald
somebody call the police
you you woody what are you doing here
hey matt
relax the detective was across the
street the whole time
we knew jason would send somebody
what who do you think told jason you
went to the police in the first place
i did harvey showed me the results of
the dna test two splotches
jason blacks and yours
okay um uh i want to file a report
oh sure i'll take you downtown you
look through the books maybe you find
something maybe you don't your real
problem isn't that guy
it's jason black somebody was gonna turn
him in once before
and i think you know the lengths he'll
go to to shut somebody up
no i don't no i don't we were here this
time we won't be here next time
next time what would happen if you were
to kill me this time well you'd be dead
and we'd have caught the guy and used
him to put jason away from murder
[ __ ] we should have done that yeah
harvey behave what do you want what do
you want from me what do you want from
me
confess to the crime turn in jason black
no i can't do that yes you can i'll tell
you why you were 16
a juvenile that's three years maximum
less if you're the one who comes forward
we'll get you a deal oh you can't make
that promise you're not the d.a you'd
rather negotiate with jason
because he'll kill you and you know it
it was his idea i don't want to do it i
didn't want to do it
okay get dressed and come with me go
hey by the way how did you get that
bruise
sometimes a good guy's got to do bad
things to make the bad guys pay that's
right
soliz has not only agreed to drop the
suit but to retire from the game as well
well maybe you're not the [ __ ] i
thought you were i'm not done yet
in return you're never gonna talk about
him again on the air
so he walks away with his reputation
intact that's the deal
no no no you know i'm right and you want
me to step off the gas right when i got
him
screw that you want to know how i know
you're right
mike i believe you know ruben hernandez
you said you wouldn't tell anyone i was
your source i didn't tell them
i did [ __ ] hey mike get him out of
here i promise we'll fix this come on
you son of a [ __ ] you're supposed to be
on my side this is me being on your side
you make me win this in court i'll have
to do it by making
reuben testify so the cost of ruining
seliza's reputation will be that kid's
career
and by the way everyone will think the
same as he does you gave him up to save
your own ass
that's a lie it doesn't matter they'll
think it anyway but hey that's just one
man's opinion
you want to protect your source take the
deal
gentlemen as you are now in control of
the company we thought it best to bring
a problem to your attention
how selfless of you these are amended
copies of the allegations against your
company by the jarvis homeowners
association
nice try i looked into those allegations
not a single expert has backed one of
their claims
oh one has now keith hoyt who better to
speak to the harmful effects than the
man who designed the wind farm himself
no no if he goes through with this that
company goes out of business there's no
way he kills his own company
you're right he wouldn't but i would and
as you pointed out
keith's judgment has been impaired
lately so i convinced him to let me make
the decisions going forward
i now have power of attorney and i'd
rather see this company worth nothing
than let you have it this is [ __ ]
let him finish something's coming
we have three choices here we move
forward with the suit
lose lose we can give you your money
back plus the 500
000 or you and i can play poker for it
and i'm not giving you your money back
harvey specter has refused to take a
mandatory drug test
leaving me no choice but to terminate
his employment
as is his right he's requested a hearing
to dispute this
thank you daniel but i'm not here to
dispute anything
after all i was high i was high because
i was being forced to work for you
a man who it turns out knew cm was
negligent
before i ever even took the case uh this
is not the time shut up louis
don't do this if you go i go
do you deny knowing about the defects
unequivocally
and you deny writing this memo sending
it to tanner knowing that he would come
after this entire firm
that's why he settled because you told
him it wouldn't hold up
well it's wild conjecture and it's
[ __ ] why'd he settle he settled
because i did
what i do that is not an answer yes
it is this ends here the two
of you have now slandered me which
violates the morality clause
of the partner's agreement it's not
slander if it's the truth unfortunately
you don't have a shred of evidence
because the evidence doesn't exist well
actually it does
this is a partners only meeting so have
tanner sue me but in the meantime
i think the rest of the partners are
gonna want to see this it's a signed
affidavit from lawrence kemp
stating that he told daniel hartman
about the defects in the cm hood six
years ago may 7th was the date of that
meeting per your calendar to be exact
you just denied knowing anything about
that unequivocally
i guess you were just lying to cover up
the fact that you were behind this
entire suit
in the first place is that
the basis of this a coerced lie from a
man trying to say
my lawyer made me do it no way that
holds up in court
doesn't have to just has to make these
harvard educated lawyers understand
that you made each and every one of them
spend a hundred thousand dollars of
their own money
to buy you control of my firm i think
we've heard all we needed to hear
harvey has admitted to violating the
drug policy
all those in favor of his dismissal
looks like you lost i'm glad you brought
up the bylaws
fraudulently suing your own firm is
grounds for firing
you have no proof of that all those in
favor of daniel hardman's dismissal
hey harvey i know i'm not a partner with
you modified go ahead nice
daniel that three million dollars of our
money
you've spent on yourself
consider your partnership bought out
you